zowie and jonathan make it official
holding hands while out on the stroll in
LA the HGTV star gives a quick nod to
the camera while the actress offers a
subtle way it's the latest sighting of
the new couple who met while filming
carpool karaoke in August you are
partnered up with the ditional sisters
yeah who are professional singers we
didn't realize that sure it's a big show
and a lot of people are obsessed with
this show and so then all sudden you're
like am I on key right are we gonna
swerve into traffic here though
announcer split from husband Jacob Hesh
Nick earlier this month after four years
of marriage and two children as for
Jonathan the Canadian stars split from
longtime girlfriend Jacinta kouznetsov
last April
now he and the new girl star have been
taking things slow a source tells Us
Weekly quote it's a very new
relationship they live in different
places and they both work a lot but when
they do get together it has been a lot
of fun and they are excited to see where
it goes and the couple have another avid
supporter his twin brother Drew tells Us
Weekly it's exciting and it means I get
to get John out here and spend more time
with us in LA over in Rome the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex are spotted beaming at
the wedding of their friend Misha nunu
the fashion designer who worked with
Meagan on her recent smart Brooks
collection it's also been reported that
Misha had a hand in introducing Harry
and Megan long before they were husband
and wife other stars in attendance for
the festivities include Katy Perry and
Orlando Bloom James Corden and Harry's
cousin Princess Beatrice the I Do's also
serve as a handy pit stop for the Royals
on their way to Africa were they and
baby Archie will take an official tour
of the continent starting next week